und namen gebe zuschauer 22 uhr 14 haben
wir es das sind unsere gäste heute abend
und hier ist unser thema das waren dann
doch zu viele treffer die armin laschet
kassieren musste jetzt hat der
cdu-vorsitzende sich selbst zur
disposition gestellt was das für seine
partei bedeutet und für das land das
gerade eine neue regierung sucht es ist
viel liegen geblieben reformstau nannte
man das früher wir müssen reden mit
diesen gästen
friedrich merz der cdu politiker sagt
armin laschet macht den weg frei für den
neuanfang der cdu
melanie amann für die spiegel
journalisten ist die cdu in einer
sinnkrise
jessica rosenthal die juso-vorsitzende
sagt wir werden nicht am katzentisch von
olaf scholz sitzen
und stellte mir der grünen politiker
fordert das muss sich nicht nur die
farbe ändern sondern auch die art zu
regieren
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und
wir haben ein bisschen das programm
geändert heute aus aktuellem anlass
logischerweise es liegt nebel über
jamaika aber eben offensichtlich auch
nebel über der zukunft von armin laschet
wir signalisieren
fdp und grünen
ansprechpartner für die cdu bleibt der
cdu vorsitzende es geht nicht um die
person armin laschet an der person wird
es nicht scheitern wenn man zu anderen
lösungen kommen will ist dies möglich
zur personellen zukunft und
neuaufstellung werde ich den gremien der
partei der kommenden woche die
einberufung eines parteitags vorschlagen
so friedrich merz ist bei uns zwei mal
versucht den cdu vorsitz zu übernehmen
und im zukunfts team von armin laschet
haben sie es verstanden geht er jetzt
oder bleibt er
hat uns ja alle etwas überrascht was
heute geschehen ist als wir uns vor gut
einer woche hier verabredet hatten
wollten wir nicht über
wirtschaftspolitik sprechen aber nun
haben sich die ereignisse überstürzt ja
ich habe es verstanden es gibt beim
parteitag und es gibt einen neuanfang
und davon sind sie überzeugt das wird
jetzt was für einen prozess einen
abstieg abgang auf raten 9 zunächst
einmal ich finde aber in der stadt hat
respekt verdient und auch anerkennung
für das was heute gesagt hat es wird
einen neuanfang geben in der cdu aber es
gibt einen vorsitzenden bis zu diesem
neuanfang und die cdu es ansprechbar für
gespräche über eine regierungsbildung
wenn die grünen wenn die fdp mit uns
reden will dann dieser vorsitzende es
ist schade er ist selbstverständlich und
dann wird es einen neuanfang geben mit
einem neu gewählten vorstand der cdu das
ist die klare botschaft von armin
laschet orte gewesen und für die große
werden die klare botschaft sagen sie und
für diverse große eventualität dass man
über jamaika noch verhandelt dieser
armin laschet verhandeln oder würden sie
dann im lauf dieser wechsel solange
dieser vorstand und dieser vorsitzende
im amt ist ist dieser vorsitzende im amt
und das ist der ansprechpartner für alle
die mit der cdu deutschlands reden
wollen eigentlich ganz einfach das
klingt total einfach aber irgendwie kann
man es noch nicht so richtig verstehen
weil man würde ja dann auch einfach
formulieren können also da sagt ja
jemand ich bin habe die rückendeckung
für diese verhandlungen ich stehe zur
verfügung es gibt große aufgaben ich
will versöhnen das klingt jetzt nicht
danach als würde er wirklich
sagen wollen ich mach den weg frei nein
er hat von neuaufstellung und neuanfang
gesprochen und es gibt kein vakuum bei
uns es gibt keine kein übergang ohne
führung und das ist angesichts der lage
des landes nach diesem bundestagswahlen
ja auch richtig aber die verantwortung
für regierungsgespräche liegt jetzt bei
den sozialdemokraten bei den liberalen
und bei den grünen aber die cdu ist
bereit zu sprechen und das finde ich ist
doch eine vernünftige und sehr
anerkennenswerter botschaft melanie
amann sitzt ihnen neben ihnen die vom
spiegel leiterin des hauptstadtbüros
frau ammann haben sie das auch so
verstanden dass es eigentlich alles
völlig klar ist oder reibt man sich
verwundert die augen und sagt in welchen
prozess begibt sich jetzt eigentlich die
cdu und wie lange soll der gute frage
also ich hab mir das statement auch
zweimal angehört ehrlich gesagt weil
mehr am anfang auch nicht so ganz klar
war was da jetzt die botschaft war und
dann für mich waren es dann zwei
botschaften eigentlich also die eine
betraf jamaika die andere betraf ihn
selbst schrägstrich die cdu schrägstrich
den parteivorsitz und das eine mit dem
anderen verknüpft weiter im moment noch
die lebensversicherung von entlastet ist
also so lange jamaika noch irgendwie im
raum stehen solange die türen nicht
komplett zugeschlagen wurde von den
grünen spd und fdp oder so lange ist
laschet ja noch ein bisschen im spiel
und deswegen hat er erst mal ausführlich
erzählt was das klang wie so eine mini
regierungserklärung was er da alles dann
machen könnte mit jamaica und was er für
die start ups machen würde und so wie
man sich von so etwas staunt zuhört und
dann kam der teil der aber denke ich
jetzt der entscheidende wird in den
nächsten tagen das signal ich bin bereit
den parteivorsitz abzugeben
es könnte für einen märz einen dritten
anlauf vielleicht geben wird ein
parteitag gehen wo eine neue führung
gewählt wird und ich glaube jetzt
beginnt der prozess den wir nicht mehr
kontrollieren kann weil jetzt wird sich
in den nächsten tagen zeigen hat er die
autorität wirklich diesen prozess noch
zu gestalten zu gestalten von vorne zu
führen wie schon eingriff kam
karrenbauer ist versucht hat und es ist
ja auch nicht gelungen denn auch ak hat
er ja gesagt ich gebe ich den
parteivorsitz auf aber ich führe das
jetzt noch weiter bis ein neuer
vorsitzender gefunden so man habe in den
monaten danach gesehen sie hat keine
autorität diesen prozess zu führen das
hat sich eine dynamik entwickelt die sie
letztlich nicht kontrollieren konnte und
ich glaube genau so wird es jetzt auch
mit händler schritt sein cem özdemir ist
bei uns von den grünen das finden wir
wozu ehemalige parteivorsitzende und hat
im jahr 2017 dieses jamaika-bündnis das
erste gedachte aus verhandeln wollen
darüber reden wir natürlich heute auch
noch erste mir finden sie fanden sie ist
er in welcher art und weise armin
laschet prügel bezogen hat also erstmal
der heutige tag jetzt nicht dazu
beigetragen dass die grünen und die fdp
die entscheidung jetzt erstmal mit der
spd gemeinsam zu reden büro in oder das
gefühl haben sie hätten sich teils
völlig
ihrer ersten frage
ich habe ja mal gesagt das ist eine
gesamten gesamtkunstwerk gewesen das
wahlergebnis der cdu csu hatte armin
laschet natürlich zweifelsohne das sagte
glaube ich selber auch dazu beigetragen
durch fehler aber man könnte sie als
bürgerliche tugenden bezeichnen und
sagen da haben andere schon auch kräftig
mitgeholfen ich denke an den
ministerpräsidenten von bayern und viele
andere das finde ich schon sehr
bemerkenswert dass jetzt alle dass quasi
bei ihm abladen und so tun als ob der
rest des ladens so gar nichts damit zu
ich habe die union nicht zu coachen sie
müssen ihren weg nach übergehen die
nachfolge frage klären aber man könnte
auf die idee kommt das vielleicht auch
noch ein paar andere den heutigen tag
nutzen können und zu sagen vielleicht
habe ich auch nicht alles richtig
gemacht mit dem waldweg bemerkenswert
sie war alles rum und alle haben alles
richtig gemacht und fast alle haben
alles richtig gemacht einer ganz
besonders darüber reden wir sofort der
gegenwind war heftig und zum schluss
vielleicht zu heftig wir schauen mal
nach den ursachen
ein abschied auf raten
gestern noch sagte der cdu-vorsitzende
und kanzlerkandidat der union wir stehen
bereit als gesprächspartner cdu und csu
doch die csu knallt die tür zu söder
will kurzerhand laschets kanzler träume
beerdigen und jamaika gleich mit jetzt
haben wir allerdings eine
vorentscheidung und klarheit durch fdp
und grüne facto eine absage an jamaika
jetzt ist ampel die klare nummer eins
wir bleiben zwar gesprächsbereit aber
nicht in einer art dauer lauerstellung
die fdp ist empört ohne die permanenten
csu blutgrätschen gegen armin laschet
könnten wir morgen sondierungsgespräche
für eine jamaika koalition beginnen
frauenfeld armin laschet oder wird er
gestürzt
ich denke er hat verhindert dass er
gestürzt wird sondern er jetzt ist nur
noch die frage wieviel gestaltungs
einfluss wird er noch haben in der
partei also auf der regierungs bildungs
ebene sehe ich für ihn
überhaupt keine chance mehr jetzt noch
etwas zu bewegen da sind ja die anderen
jetzt am zug und ich glaube die werden
das auch hinkriegen eine regierung zu
bilden aber er wird nicht gestürzt
werden er wird irgendwann dann abtreten
es geschafft dass er nicht
rausgeschmissen wird dass ihn keiner
absägen muss dass er nicht irgendwie hat
den eindruck erweckt dass er das jetzt
noch ein bisschen selber gestaltet hat
auch sondergrößen hat aber nie aufgehört
armin laschet zu bekämpfen ja das stimmt
und ja das stimmt haben erzählt ihnen
eine andere antwort auf die frage ein
hat markus söder je aufgehört armin
laschet zu bekämpfen nachdem klar war
dass er der kanzlerkandidat der union
über 60 prozent der wählerinnen und
wähler in deutschland haben die union
bis zum wahltag als zerstritten
angesehen und zerstrittene parteien
werden nicht gewählt das ist die ganz
einfache schlussfolgerung
wobei ich vor einmal in einem punkte
widersprechen möchte im internet hat den
prozess der nachfolge in nordrhein
westfalen in den letzten tagen gut
moderiert und wir werden hierzu einen
prozess haben der deutlich kürzer
an dauert als der prozess den wir nach
dem rücktritt von annegret kramp
karrenbauer hatten der hat fast ein jahr
gedauert insofern bin ich zuversichtlich
dass irgendwas jetzt auch gelingt ich
wünsche symbian teils noch mal frage
nach markus söder sie sind mit armin
laschet befreundet das haben sie selber
gesagt hast du mir glauben sie denken
sie dass markus söder kein wichtiges
oder wichtigstes interesse hatte als
armin laschet zu besiegen der journalist
interesse bayern ist eine landtagswahl
die nächste und ich glaube bringt sich
in stellung für die nächste
bundestagswahl ist mein eindruck aber
auch da die union muss ihre
personalpolitik machen wir waren unsere
als bürger dieses landes würde ich mir
allerdings wünschen soll das jetzt so
kommen dass das jamaika gibt in der
ergebnisoffenen rein schauen was nächste
wo herauskommt ziehen dann gemeinsamen
strich und dann muss man das bewerten
den sitzen hat ja gesagt der robert
habeck der keks ist noch nicht ganz
gegessen ist glaube ich auch sinnvoll
mit blick auf die spd dass die spd sie
ihre sache jetzt auch nicht so ganz
sicher ist sondern auch die gespräche so
führt dass wir uns darauf augen eben
irgendwie begegnen aber nochmal zurück
als staatsbürger würde ich mir schon
wünschen weil wir werden im bundesrat ja
dann einander brauchen es gibt viele
dinge die kann die bundesregierung
alleine gar nicht beschließen wenn ich
mir anschaue wie viel ändern die union
eine regierungsbeteiligung hat würde ich
mir wünschen dass der umgang miteinander
ist das schon die ganze infrastruktur
projekt die letzten 16 jahre leider
nicht vorangekommen stichwort
digitalisierung die riesige ökologische
gleich das will man zeigen dass soweit
miteinander umgehen können das monster
eigentlich gegenseitig blockieren am
ende des tages haben auch ihre länder
nixdorf nichts davon wir sind noch mal
bei armin laschet würden die grünen
überhaupt mit jemandem anderen als armin
laschet den ja zunächst gewählten
kanzlerkandidaten verhandeln sollte es
jemals noch diese kleine chance michael
geben ich wiederhole was sie vorher
gesagt haben wir machen nicht die
personalpolitik der union
wir haben doch auch gesagt und das gilt
für die fdp als auch für die grünen ja
das ist um die inhalte geht es geht aber
natürlich auch die verlässlichkeit wenn
sie müssen ja im gesprächspartner in die
augen schauen das gefühl haben dass es
für das selbe oder diese und immer ist
verlässlich und bin ich da eine
unterschrift mache zum beispiel sagt
kohleausstieg 2030 dann sollte ich auch
den eindruck erwecken dass ich das mit
meinen eigenen reihen durchsetzen kann
ja auch das gehört zur gesamtbewertung
sodann hat er das jetzt sehr freundlich
ausgedrückt und wir begrüssen endlich
jessica rosenthal die juso-vorsitzende
sie sind neu im bundestag vor rosenthal
und haben heute natürlich diesen tag
sicherlich auch irgendwie mit erstaunen
zur kenntnis genommen und auch
angeschaut was in der union da passiert
in der cdu würden sie sagen es ist
eigentlich wie im wahlkampf
man braucht sich gegenseitig zu sorgen
die chancen und nimmt sich damit
komplett aus dem spiel ist für sie die
union jetzt schon erledigt also ich muss
ehrlich sagen dass ich die debatte auch
rund um jamaika auch gerade die die
union immer wieder aufmacht mit relativ
viel erstaunen beobachte weil wir
einfach klar sagen müssen es gibt ein
wahlverlierer und das ist die union und
es gibt auch heute und die letzten tage
ein klares bekenntnis die ampel zu
verhandeln ich habe zumindest das
statement heute sehr optimistisch
wahrgenommen ich habe gesehen dass da
glaube ich genau das passieren soll sie
auch gerade gesagt haben augenhöhe und
dafür braucht es nicht am firmament die
drehstrom von jamaika für uns als spd
sondern das ist eine politische kultur
frage das ist etwas wie will man diesen
fortschritt in dem land wirklich
organisieren und das geht auf augenhöhe
und das habe ich auch wahrgenommen und
deshalb muss ich klar sagen die union
war für mich schon am wahlabend und in
den tagen danach wahlverliererin ich
glaube sie muss jetzt selber ihre
personalprozesse für sich regeln ich
kann aber klar sagen ich glaube am ende
kommt es auch auf inhalte an und ich
habe im wahlkampf sehr stark auch
gesehen das ist eigentlich eine partei
ist die inhaltlich ziemlich entkernt ist
das haben sie ja auch schon ähnlich mal
formuliert und von daher ist es glaube
ich ein längerfristiger prozess der
mische ich mich aber von außen auch
nicht könnte wir reden auch unbedingt
noch über olaf scholz und über seinen
rückhalt in seiner partei und in seiner
fraktion und sind jetzt herr merz aber
erstmal noch mal bei der frage wie
stellt man sich das in der zukunft mit
markus söder vor wird der jetzt weil er
ja eigentlich jamaika schon
verabschiedet hat und gesagt hat es geht
jetzt alles auf die ampel
wird der eigentlich nun zur union noch
dazugerechnet oder ist irgendwie allein
also so weit liegen doch die beiden
statements auch gar nicht auseinander
von gestern markus ja das avaya aber
markus söder hat das etwas apodiktisch
ja gesagt aber dass wir jetzt nicht in
eine endlosschleife gehen ist doch auch
klar und dass wir trotzdem
gesprächsbereit sind haben beide gesagt
mit etwas unterschiedlicher nuancierung
ich finde da ist eine gewisse
überinterpretation auch dabei richtig
ist dass jetzt zunächst einmal unter für
rosenthal recht die spd hat die
bundestagswahl gewonnen wir haben sie
verloren und damit liegt zunächst einmal
die aufgabe einer regierung zu versuchen
zu bilden bei den sozialdemokraten und
sie haben mit der spd mit der fdp und
den grünen gesprächspartner die dazu
bereit sind und das ist doch auch gut
wir haben einen friedlichen eine
friedliche wahl gehabt wir sind in einer
demokratie da gehört der
regierungswechsel dazu und wenn wir
positionen sind dann sind wir opposition
und da sind ja auch nicht viertes oder
fünftes rad am wagen dann sind wir
gleichberechtigt mit der regierung im
parlament und dann tragen wir die
meinungs- streitigkeiten dort aus also
ich finde zu einer dramatisierung dieser
lage gibt es überhaupt gelten diese
bundestagswahl gerne gewonnen wie hätten
sie auch gewinnen können wir was richtig
gemacht hätten aber wir haben sie halt
verloren und ist damit natürlich bei den
nächsten sofort naheliegenden frage
hatte diese union den falschen
kanzlerkandidaten sie hatte den
kanzlerkandidaten der herzlichen
errungen so schön formulierte und mit
ihnen den parteivorsitzenden er hat also
hat sich die union aus ihrer sicht zwei
mal für einen falsch menschen also nette
formulierung habe ich so nie gebraucht
aber mache ich mir zu eigen vielen dank
als liebenswürdig von ihnen jetzt mal im
ernst im grunde genommen liegen die
fehler weit zurück und im grunde
genommen kann man sogar auf ein datum
legen das war der 29 oktober 2018 das
war der tag an dem die partei akzeptiert
hat das kanzleramt und parteivorsitz
nicht mehr in einer hand liegen das war
aus der rückschau betrachtet der schwere
strategische fehler das so zu machen
danach sagt wolfgang bosbachs sofort wir
hatten drei jahre und diese drei jahre
hätten wir nutzen 19 einsätzen in der
gleichung kam ein lehrer merkel in die
show ist noch mal ich hab ja über die
partei gespielt nicht über frau merkel
die partei hat akzeptiert dass diese
beiden aufgaben voneinander getrennt
werden und das ist uns nicht gut
bekommen wenn es uns gut bekommen die
wahl geworden und das ist jetzt die lage
an der in der wir sind und damit müssen
wir umgehen und daraus müssen wir dann
auch die notwendigen trotzdem noch mal
die frage ist frage stellen auf wie
hätte denn die partei handeln sollen
wenn sie das nicht akzeptiert hätte
sagen sollen angeleiteten 1492 zusagen
sollen wir sind der meinung dass beide
aufgaben in eine hand gehören und wenn
die bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
aufhören möchte dann muss sie
akzeptieren dass auch das kanzleramt
dann
zur disposition gestellt wird das heute
mal machen vielleicht kanzlerin zu
treffen oder hätte beide ämter behalten
sollen bis zum schluss das ist
jedenfalls meine meinung und aus der
rückschau betrachtet ist es an der
stelle haben die fehler bei uns begonnen
und an der stelle hat auch die
führungskrise begonnen die wir bis heute
nicht gelöst wir sind jetzt drei jahre
in einer solchen führungskrise und das
ist der auslöser gewesen 29 oktober 2008
2018 sie wahrscheinlich vergessen und
andere wie gesagt auch von ihren
parteifreunden
interpretieren das anders ich wollte
gern noch mal auf diese diese frage nach
der entscheidung für den
spitzenkandidaten natürlich kommen weil
er jetzt ja auch eine zentrale rolle in
diesem neuen parteitag spielen soll und
überhaupt will die union will die cdu
auf eine neue art und weise ihre
kandidaten finden sowohl für das amt des
vorsitzes als auch für die
wahrscheinlich für die kanzlerschaft sie
haben ich frage es noch mal das gefühl
dass mit armin laschet das establishment
der cdu einen kandidaten durchgesetzt
hat der nicht erfolg hatte das sagen sie
sogar so ja wir haben wir haben im
grunde also fangen wir mal anders an die
eine partei muss hin und wieder in ihren
führungsgremien gegen den willen der
mitglieder auch mal entscheidungen
treffen so das kann man einmal machen
aber das kann man nicht dreimal
hintereinander machen das ist dann zwei
mal zu viel wir müssen uns für die
zukunft andere prozesse andere verfahren
überlegen wie wir solche sachen personal
entscheidungen treffen das geht einmal
für die cdu das wird jetzt nach meiner
einschätzung stattfinden das gilt aber
auch für den nicht ganz unkomplizierten
aber auch nicht so häufig stattfindenden
entscheidungsprozess um die
kanzlerkandidatur
da hat es schon mal in der früheren zeit
streit gegeben das haben wir zum dritten
mal erlebt wir brauchen dafür
institutionell zwischen cdu und anderen
verfahren und zwar bevor es um die namen
und die personen geht braucht man vorher
ein verfahren auf das wir uns dann
einigen aber das weiß jetzt jeder und
daraus müssen bis jetzt auch nicht mal
das nochmal ganz präzise das gleiche ist
der band ihre partei da gibt es namen
natürlich die die menschheit
mittlerweile auch kennt also wolfgang
schäuble volker bouffier in der letzten
entscheidenden runde aber es gibt ein
statement ihrer partei dass sie als
vorsitzenden verhindert hat hat auch
verhindert dass markus söder
kanzlerkandidat wurde das ist personen
identisch zum teil jedenfalls aber das
ist die richtige beschreibung der
geschichte die hinter uns liegt naja
nicht ganz ich das sagen darf alles ein
bisschen anders also sie wurden von
einer abstimmung unter 1000 delegierten
nicht gewählt jetzt wollen wir sogar ja
also man kann jetzt hatte ich sagen 1001
das ist jetzt das establishment aber das
ist schon relativ großes establishment
also das heißt die entscheidung als
resilienz die nicht parteivorsitzender
geworden und wurde von einem großen
kreis von personen getroffen da kann
jetzt sagen wir sind alle doof die mich
nicht gewählt haben sind alle
funktionäre und verstehen die basis und
die menschen nicht okay kann man
vielleicht zu sehen aber das andere
gremium da würde ich ihnen recht geben
bei dem das gremium das den herrn
laschet gewählt hat der bundesvorstand
ihren wirklich nach einer gremien logik
entschieden und nach einem statement
denken das glaube ich der partei nicht
gut getan hat nur was sie jetzt tun und
was sie tun seit sie diese wahl zweimal
verloren haben ist ja im prinzip zu
delegitimieren dass da gewählte
demokratische in der partei gewählte
leute sozusagen nicht in der lage wären
oder eigentlich auch nicht legitimiert
werden eigentlich nur auf depeche mode
sind diese entscheidung zu treffen sehr
tun immer so als würde diese
entscheidung akzeptieren aber eigentlich
akzeptieren sie nicht sondern haben
jetzt zweimal hintereinander gesagt es
war im prinzip eine fehlentscheidung
dass ich das nicht gewonnen habe und die
leute die haben aus völlig falschen
motiven mich nicht gewählt das ist ja
das narrativ sei das ganze unruhe und
zur führungskrise in der panorama
widersprechen ganz ausdrücklich das ist
das ist ein verdienst nein das ist
falsch ist es gerade für das jahr 2021
falsch ich habe beide male die aktie
entscheidungen akzeptiert ich habe sogar
in diesem jahr 2021 den gewählten
vorsitzenden armin laschet unterstützt
auf seinem weg hin zur kanzlerschaft
kanzlerkandidatur und ich habe diesen
wahlkampf im wahlkampf wie kaum ein
zweiter aus der cdu gemacht nein nein
ich habe das nicht sogar soll ich habe
das gemacht weil ich davon überzeugt bin
dass eine demokratisch legitimierte
entscheidung wie die des
bundesparteitages richtig ist aber es
waren entscheidungen die jedes mal gegen
eine mehrheit unserer mitglieder
gerichtet war das eindeutig andere
präferenzen gegeben und daraus muss man
jetzt schlussfolgerungen ziehen mehr und
nicht mehr und nicht weniger sagt ich
hab übrigens ist dass ich jetzt noch mal
antreten sich ja da hast du wenig weit
von entfernt ich habe nur gesagt wir wir
haben jetzt eine lage wo wir auch über
die verfahren reden müssen wie wir in
zukunft parteivorsitzende wählen und wie
wir auch den kanzlerkandidaten der
beiden parteien cdu und csu nominieren
dass das müssen wir anders machen wenn
wir die partei und die mitglieder und
auch unsere wählerinnen und wähler
mitnehmen wollen wir müssen einfach
schlussfolgerungen aus diesen
erfahrungen der letzten drei jahre wenn
ich dann noch eingegangen ergänzen darf
sie haben vorhin gesagt eigentlich hätte
die partei nicht akzeptieren dürfen dass
angela merkel im amt bleibt als
kanzlerin geworden und nicht als da ist
es also okay wenn der vorstand dann sagt
frau bundeskanzlerin treten sie dann
eine beliebte bundeskanzlerin die gerade
mit mühe und not irgendwie also in den
umfragen beliebte also die gerade mit
mühe und not irgendeine regierung
zusammen gebastelt hatte nach einer wahl
zu der sie wieder angetreten war die
ganze partei sie angebettelt hat mit
trete noch mal an weil wir haben keinen
anderen also da ist es dann okay wenn
eine kleine gruppe vom establishment
sagt also du sollst jetzt nicht noch mal
im amt bleiben aber ansonsten sozusagen
ist dieses gremium dann nicht
legitimierung eine entscheidung zu
treffen weil der kanzlerkandidat ist
also mein eindruck ist dass ihre
argumentation an nicht ganz schlüssig
aber das stimmt nur wenn sie den
zeitablauf unberücksichtigt lassen ich
habe die entscheidungen des
parteivorstandes der cdu dem ich nicht
an gehöre seit vielen jahren nicht mehr
immer akzeptiert
2018 2019 20 21h akzeptiert nur was wir
heute sehen ist dass wir auch mit diesen
entscheidungen einschließlich der
personalentscheidungen eine krachende
wahlniederlage eingefahren haben da
können wir nicht sagen dass man auch
weiter so sondern das müssen wir ändern
wie wir das ändern darüber reden was
nicht
nicht dass gar nicht jetzt das hat mich
alles gar nichts anzugehen sondern es
gibt ja ein buch von dem bekannten
journalisten robin alexander wo dieser
ganze prozess ist die auswahl war warum
es armin laschet wurde und wie das
detailliert war präzise nachzulesen dass
und ich frage mich ob das der union gut
tun fragt mich aber ob das insgesamt uns
als politiker gut tut wenn quasi sitzung
in echtzeit bietet nachzulesen sind und
ich glaube nehmen der personalfrage in
die ich mich wie gesagt nicht einmischen
will aber dass das quasi leute die neben
ihm sitzen in echtzeit das was gerade
gesagt würden nachlesen ich komme ja aus
einer partei wurde es früher auch mal so
war jetzt muss man nicht jeden fehler
den die grünen frühere gemacht haben
unbedingt nachmachen gerne klimaschutz
übernehmen aber bitte nicht dass also
eine misstrauenskultur ja das ist es dem
anderen immer eine rein wirken und so
dass das tut insgesamt heißt und da
haben sie recht und ja ich glaube ein
teil des problems warum jetzt die
entscheidung auch bei fdp und grünen so
getroffen wurde wie sie getroffen das
wird erst wieder sozialen demokratie
gucken wollen ob wir da eine regierung
stabil hinkriegen hat auch was damit zu
tun dass wir wenn man ein gespräch führt
und sie die sachen nachlesen können das
ist ja keine gute haben wir uns keinen
gewerbesteuer ist übrigens haben aber
unsere baustelle absolut und das ist mit
ein grund warum ich 2004 aus allen
führungsgremien der union ausgeschieden
bin und 2009 aus dem bundestag weil wir
eine kultur des misstrauens und einer
auf anderem wege gemacht worden das ist
auf anderem wege gemacht worden wir
haben seit 20 jahren diese indiskretion
aus unseren gremien ich kann mich an den
alten verstorbenen faz redakteur karl
feldmeyer erinnern der mich nach jeder
präsidiumssitzung angerufen hatte und
mir wörtlich gesagt hat der märz nicht
lesen mal vor was sie heute morgen in
der präsidiumssitzung gesagt haben
stimmt das oder stimmt das nicht stimmte
fast immer so und und man sie war noch
nicht der grund dass sie aus der politik
aus dass dies die zweite runde war hand
finde wir müssen zurückfinden zu einer
kultur des umgangs des vertrauens
miteinander diese partei braucht wieder
eine seele sie braucht noch ein bisschen
wenn man das wort heute noch sagen darf
chorgeist ein bisschen zusammenhalt nach
innen damit wir nach außen
handlungsfähig werden das ist unser
problem sie müssen noch mal erklären
warum sie sich aus dem spiel genommen
haben um sich jetzt ja mit ganzer kraft
in das spiel wieder hineinzubegeben
nochmal sie bieten an dass nicht nur der
tweet von heute sagt sie wollen
mithelfen einen einvernehmlichen weg zu
finden auch die zustimmung unserer
mitglieder und zu beziehen sie bieten an
ja jetzt nochmal mit der basis und wen
meinen sie eigentlich wenn sie die auf
die basis rekurrieren sagen auch ich
könnte einer dieser zukünftigen ich
kandidaten soll ein dass ihn das nicht
so erwägung ich werde genannt in diesem
zusammenhang von mir gibt es in diese
richtung keine äußerung ich bin wieder
im wesen des mitte des deutschen
bundestages ich bin wieder zurück in der
aktiven politik mehr nicht ob ich noch
einmal für den parteivorsitz kandidiere
oder nicht das ist eine frage mit der
ich mich nicht abschließend beschäftigt
sie haben auch da er gesagt dass sie
jetzt ihr bedarf gedeckt ist ich habe
ich schließe eines aus ja ich esse eines
aus ich werde nicht noch einmal in eine
streitige abstimmung auf einem
bundesparteitag gehen das schließe ich
aus weil sie einem bundesparteitag
absprechen neu
ist dass der bundesparteitag muss das
entscheiden wir haben keine andere
möglichkeit die die mitglieder können
befragt werden aber die entscheiden ist
nicht so jetzt müssen uns über die
verfahren unterhalten wie wir vorgehen
armin laschet hat heute etwas sehr
wichtiges gesagt das hat er in nordrhein
westfalen erfolgreich gemacht eine
lösung im konsens und was sie von mir
heute gelesen haben war genau dass ich
werde mich daran beteiligen eine lösung
im konsens zu finden weil mein bedarf an
streitigen personalentscheidungen ist
jedoch die frage sie sprechen einem
parteitag der cdu ab einen parteilosen
zu wählen weil das eine
eine zusammensetzung ist oder einen
auserwählten gram jungen dass sie nicht
akzeptiert also
noch mal ich habe doch gerade ganz klar
und deutlich gesagt der parteitag der
cdu dort wo es tauchen des einst
delegierten entscheidet über den
nächsten bundesvorstand ja die frage wie
wir die basis unsere 400.000 mitglieder
in diese entscheidung mit einbeziehen
ist eine offene frage steht in unserer
satzung dass wir zur personal- und
sachfragen eine mitgliederbefragung
durchführen können ob wir das jetzt
machen ist eine diskussion die in der
partei geführt wird darüber wird es
wahrscheinlich am nächsten montag im
bundesvorstand eine diskussion gehen ich
finde es richtig dass wir über
mitgliederbeteiligung sprechen er los
und daran will ich mich beteiligen und
an nicht als andere die prozesse in der
union im personalpolitik sind natürlich
sehr spannend aber noch spannender finde
ich witzig nach dem wunder halten wie es
mit dem land weiter ja was passiert mit
klimaschutz ist auch
jetzt wieder der großen politik wäre es
mit europa aber vielleicht könnten wir
sie sind einverstanden vielleicht
könnten wir uns trotzdem noch mal fragen
was sie glauben doch da mische ich mich
nicht ein es war nur eine anregung die
sie machen das immer ganz entzückend und
satt und herr merz ist sicherlich auch
dankbar wir gucken trotzdem noch mal
darauf was das bedeutet wenn die cdu
sich aus wenn die union sich aus dem
rennen nimmt
wenn peter altmaier sagt wir haben die
lektion diese 26.9 gelernt dann würden
sie denken was ist das für eine lektion
die die volkspartei cdu mit einem
wahlergebnis von 24,1 gelernt hat und
ich frage auch sie das gleich weil es
bedeutet ja tatsächlich etwas für das
land und es bedeutet etwas für
regierungsbündnisse die geschlossen
werden können wir reden ja jetzt nicht
nur über interior
deshalb setzt man sich zusammen und
schaut was wie weit geht die union beim
klimaschutz wie weit geht es bei der
modernisierung des landes wie
finanzieren wir das ganze ist ja auch
nicht so unwichtig weil schöne zu sagen
kann jeder machen wenn es nicht auch
etatisiert ist und das gleiche machen
wir mit der spd und jetzt haben wir uns
mit der fdp gemeinsam was glaube ich
auch eine andere kultur darstellt im
verhältnis zu früher entschieden dass
wir gesagt haben mit der spd wollen wir
jetzt zuerst mal die gespräche führen
sondieren am ende werden es bilanzieren
dann wird werden wir eine entscheidung
treffen die fdp und die spd sicher auch
und werden unseren gremien entscheiden
wie es weitergeht und wände scheitern
sollte was ich nicht hoffe dann werden
wir auch wieder gespräche führen mit der
union zusammen mit der fdp katrin
göring-eckardt hat gesagt sie spricht
der union das war noch vor dem tag heute
dass die sanierungsfähigkeit und erst
recht die was war das
regierungsfähigkeit ab was sagen sie
entscheidend ist was unsere beiden
parteivorsitzenden der lena werbung &
republic soll weiß ich habe mich am 1
ich habe eine meinung hat sich getraut
das hat hier nichts mit mutproben zu tun
also was damit zu tun dass die
viertgrößte volkswirtschaft dieser welt
seriös regiert werden muss und dass der
prozess wie man so eine regierung bildet
auch was mit seriosität zu tun hat mit
ernsthaftigkeit zu tun hatte damit zu
tun hat das war auch weiß dass wir das
nicht nur für uns machen so dass der
viel draußen viele leute gerade zu
schauen und auch so ein bisschen das
gefühl haben wollten wir haben es ja
nicht mit kasperl zu tun sagt leuten wie
vielleicht sich auch bewusst darüber
sind dass unsere entscheidungen die wir
treffen so oder so ging das leben von
menschen ein grill absolut und es ist
eben nur gerade es sind zwei
volksparteien mit
wirklich unterdurchschnittlichen
wahlergebnissen aus dieser wahl gegangen
und auch das hat ja eine konsequenz für
das regiert werden wobei zu führen das
muss man sagen die spd war jetzt vor
einigen monaten irgendwie noch näher bei
10% wie wir 20 prozent und jetzt hat sie
nun wirklich kräftig zugelegt also muss
man ehrlich ist
der wahlsieger so und sagen rosenthal
jetzt gibt es im grunde genommen nach
allen auslegungen im guten noch mehr
ampel chancen nach dem was armin laschet
heute gesagt hat weil nun eben ein
langer prozess wahrscheinlich in der
union losgehen wird kann die spd ist
meine frage an sie das jetzt noch
vermasselt und werden die jusos daran
einen anteil haben also ich muss ehrlich
sagen dass gerade die letzte debatte die
wir gerade hier geführt haben hier schon
deutlich zeigt dass es gut ist dass wir
jetzt diese ampel sondierung und führen
und ich kann auch sagen als junge
politikerin jetzt neu im bundestag ist
nicht alleine sondern zusammen mit
vielen jungen menschen der jusos war
auch der grünen jugend und auch anderen
die wirklich etwas verändern will würde
ich mich wirklich freundin wird nicht
nur über die vergangenheitsbewältigung
der union sprechen sondern über die
zukunft die uns betrifft und da sehe ich
natürlich sehe ich natürlich
gemeinsamkeiten die wir haben mit der
ampel und das besteht nicht nur darin
dass die union vielleicht zerrissen ist
sondern auch darin dass es große
übereinstimmungen gibt insbesondere
zwischen den grünen und der spd
programmatisch aber ich glaube auch dass
ich unter seiner fortschritts erzählung
etwas neues formieren kann das wird von
allen seiten betont das sehe ich auch in
dem was gesagt worden ist dass man eben
sagt wir wollen am ende mehr sein als
die summe die die einst sind irgendwie
mitbringen und das versuchen wir auch
mit einer neuen kultur das finde ich
richtig und das muss auch passieren es
gibt aber natürlich punkte und da wären
die grünen welchen können da kann die
fdp welchen und da kann die spd welchen
ich als juso vorsitzende kann erst recht
wenn der programmatische arbeit uns ganz
besonders wichtig ist gibt es punkte die
sehr wichtig sind und genau die sollen
jetzt ausgelotet werden da gibt es auch
ein großes vertrauen auch meinerseits in
die dafür und sondieren aber es ist auch
klar die jusos gehen nicht vom tisch
wenn da nicht was für junge menschen
drin ist wenn wir auch in der frage was
tun das bei niedrigen und unteren
einkommen wirklich was ankommt dass die
löhne steigen all diese punkte und da
könnten die grünen jetzt glaube ich noch
weitere punkte denn über klimaschutz
weiß ich auch von der grünen jugend sind
wir ganz ganz ganz viele runden zusammen
also deswegen die inhalte sind
entscheiden und das ist doch das neue an
dem was da passiert endlich mal inhalte
die konstruktiv besprochen werden und
nicht nur personal oder irgendwelche
querelen die irgendwo debattiert werde
so aber es gibt und enttäuscht ich sie
jetzt nicht sondern sie sind darauf
vorbereitet und natürlich gewappnet es
gibt natürlich auch die frage frauen
teilt wie sehr die fraktion im deutschen
bundestag die jetzt 49 jusos mehr hat
und die juso-vorsitzende dabei hat wie
sehr die eigentlich olaf scholz das
leben leicht oder schwer machen wird
also auch olaf scholz war ja
offensichtlich ein kandidat nicht des
herzens der partei sonst wäre er gewählt
worden und er ist nicht gewählt worden
sondern ist das kersten und norbert
walter borjans ich will jetzt nicht
sagen dass sie ein ähnliches problem
haben aber man könnte fragen ist eine
basis entscheidung zwingend die richtige
entscheidung wenn es um eine
kanzlerkandidatur geht dich jetzt eine
total freundliche frage die da durfte er
werden ich muss ganz klar sagen sie
finden eine spd vor die so geschlossen
ist wie selten zuvor wie nie wie viele
sagen und das hat vor allem den grund
dass wir uns programmatisch geeinigt
haben wir haben diskutiert haben auch
gestritten wie waren unterschiedlicher
meinung es gibt immer noch punkte wo wir
unterschiedlicher meinung sind wir sind
eine programmpartei und das macht ihn
mitglieder im übrigen auch aus das macht
auch spaß an der spd damals gesagt und
ist der malermeister der berg dass es
von sozialdemokratischer partei weg
gemalt der punkt ist da müssen die rhein
eine gemeinsame basis haben und das ist
das zukunftsprogramm da steht nämlich
genau das drin wo wir uns geeinigt haben
es gab die auseinandersetzung um den
parteivorsitz und da gibt es sicherlich
auch viele punkte wo wir im nachhinein
wahrscheinlich prozesse anders steuern
würden trotzdem muss man klar sagen das
ist was anderes ist ob ich eine parteien
parteivorsitzender bin oder ein
kanzlerkandidat und es gab keinerlei
dissens wenn man sich die nominierung
von olaf scholz anguckt dass er der
richtige kanzlerkandidat ist es ist aber
auch gut und richtig dass wir
unterschiedliche rollen haben gerade
weil wir programmatisch so viel arbeiten
und das finde ich völlig richtig deshalb
kann ich heute auch sagen ins
juso-vorsitzende es ist nicht so dass
wir nicht hinter olaf scholz stehen oder
dass er nicht unsere hundertprozentige
unterstützung hat aber natürlich ist
damit verbunden dass wir auch inhalte
die wir gemeinsam im zukunftsprogramm
aufgeschrieben habe umsetzen wollen und
ich glaube das überrascht wirklich
niemand überrascht niemanden aber auch
herr kümmert hat ja gesagt dass es eine
mitgliederbefragung geben wird wenn
ihnen das jetzt nicht gefällt was ihr
olaf scholz jetzt offensichtlich auch
kanzler kandidat der herzen das urlaubs
aufgeschrieben habe würden sie dann auch
sagen da muss jetzt die nächste
begründeten gegenbewegung gegründet
werden die heißt dann nicht mehr nur
groß sondern neue ampel also erst mal
kann man sagen man kann sich darauf
verlassen dass die jusos programmatisch
definitiv ganz genau hingucken aber es
ist auch nicht so und das finde ich sehr
wichtig in der demokratie dass olaf
scholz alleine deinem tisch sitzt der
sitzen auch noch andere am tisch und ich
bin mir sicher das ist nicht nur um
sondierungsgespräche geht sondern auch
um koalitionsverhandlungen und auch dort
werden vielleicht sogar noch mehr
menschen tisch sein und diese partei ist
geprägt von vielen vielen gesichtern und
nicht nur von unserem kanzlerkandidat
eine führende rolle keine frage aber am
ende des tages werden wir das gemeinsam
verhandeln und dann natürlich auch
gemeinsam bewerten das doch für die
richter